This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. My guest today is Keith Chen. He's a behavioral economist at UCLA. He's also the head of economic research at Uber, the right-sharing company. Keith's going to talk about some of the behavioral anomalies that Uber has observed, and we're then going to talk about some of Keith's earlier work, which explored the evolutionary and cultural origins of certain biases and heuristics.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦达坦姆。我今天的嘉宾是基思·陈。他是加州大学洛杉矶分校的行为经济学家，也是拼车公司优步（Uber）经济研究主管。基思将谈谈优步观察到的一些行为反常现象，然后我们还将讨论基思早期的部分研究，这些研究探索了某些偏见和启发法的进化与文化起源。
Keith Chen, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me, and the big fan of the podcast. I wanna start by talking about surge pricing. Uber charges more when demand is high, based on the idea that this is gonna draw more drivers into the pool and increase the supply of rights. Now this makes perfect sense from the point of view for traditional economists, but you're
基思·陈，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我来，我是这个播客的超级粉丝。我想从激增定价（surge pricing）开始聊起。当需求旺盛时，优步会收取更高的费用，其理念是这将吸引更多司机加入并增加乘车供应。现在，从传统经济学家的角度来看，这完全合情合理，但你
a behavioral economist and you must know there's something about charging different prices for the same products that rubs customers the wrong way. They say, hey, five minutes ago this ride was $10, now it's 20. As you can imagine, I hear over and over again, both at my dinner table and at family gatherings that search pricing can feel very unfair to customers. But it's been a really integral part of Uber success precisely because the whole goal of the company was to replace a really frustrating experience with taxi, with service that's just ultimately reliable.
是一名行为经济学家，你肯定知道，对同一种产品收取不同的价格，这种做法会惹恼客户。他们会说，嘿，五分钟前这趟车才10美元，现在就要20美元了。正如你所想象的，我在餐桌上和家庭聚会上一次又一次地听到人们抱怨，激增定价让客户感到很不公平。但它确实是优步成功的一个不可或缺的部分，因为公司的整个目标就是用一种最终绝对可靠的服务，去取代令人极为沮丧的传统出租车体验。
And the only way to do that, the only way to be able to get basically everyone who lives in a dense part of a city, a car within five minutes, was to do that through dynamic pricing, through giving drivers a very, very strong incentive to want to get to the places where they're needed the most. And also, to get riders who could afford to wait a little longer, say they're at a bar to say, well, you know, if it's more expensive to take a ride right now, go ahead and relax and sit back. If you can wait 15 minutes, the drinks on the person who's got to go now.
而做到这一点的唯一方法，能够让基本上生活在城市稠密区的每个人在五分钟内都叫到车的唯一方法，就是通过动态定价，通过给予司机非常非常强烈的激励，让他们前往最需要他们的那些地方。同时，也能让那些能多等一会儿的乘客——比如他们正在酒吧里——觉得，好吧，你知道的，如果现在打车更贵，那就接着放松，坐下来。如果你能等15分钟，酒钱就由那个现在必须离开的人来出。
Right. The interesting thing, Keith, is that when I think about my own behavior, when Uber tells me the price is now 1.8 times the regular price, I notice that and I factor that in and there's a part of me that feels it's a little unfair. When I'm waiting for just a taxi cab and now the taxi cab doesn't show up, I don't actually think of someone whom I can blame or someone whom I hold responsible, even though it actually has a bigger effect on me, that now I actually have to wait two hours or I can't get a cab at all. Yeah, that's absolutely right.
没错。有趣的是，基思，当我想到我自己的行为时，当优步告诉我现在的价格是正常价格的1.8倍时，我注意到了这一点，我将其考虑在内，我心里有一部分觉得这有点不公平。而当我只是在等一辆出租车，结果出租车没来时，我其实并没有觉得有什么人可以怪罪，或者有什么人需要承担责任，尽管它实际上对我的影响更大——现在我居然得等上两个小时，或者根本叫不到车。是的，完全正确。
And, you know, this basic question of how psychologically painful kind of the experience of paying a price is, is something that I worry about every day, especially because I actually think that it's one of the reasons that we've grown so fast. It's one of the reasons that we've been able to displace taxi so quickly is because in a taxi you sit in the car and when you're trapped in traffic, you literally watch your money taking away, like in front of you, you're just kind of forced to watch it. There's nothing else to see except it's hypnotic. It's hypnotic, and it's the worst possible psychological experience.
而且，你知道，支付价格的心理体验有多痛苦这个基本问题，是我每天都在担心的事，尤其是因为我实际上认为，这是我们发展如此迅速的原因之一。这也是我们能够如此迅速取代出租车的原因之一，因为在出租车里，你坐在车里，当被困在交通拥堵中时，你眼睁睁地看着自己的钱在流失，就像在你面前一样，你只是被迫看着它。除了这个，没什么可看的，它具有催眠作用。它具有催眠作用，而且是可能产生的最糟糕的心理体验。
Taxis and gas pumps, right? Or the two places where you just watch your money take away. And the typical Uber experience, you know, you just hit a button, get in the car, and if it's not surging, you don't even need to know what you paid until tomorrow morning, if you want to open the email, and if you kind of trust the Uber's the kind of cheapest possible option, you don't even need to look. So you found that psychology plays a role in how search pricing works because there are places where it works in the way that a traditional economist would predict it would work and there
出租车和加油站，对吧？这是两个你只能眼睁睁看着钱流失的地方。而在典型的优步体验中，你知道的，你只需按一个按钮，上车，如果没有激增定价，你甚至不需要知道你付了多少钱，直到明天早上如果你想打开电子邮件的话；如果你有点信任优步是最便宜的选择，你甚至都不需要去看。所以你发现心理学在激增定价的运作方式中发挥了作用，因为有些地方它的运作方式正如传统经济学家所预测的那样，而有些地方
are places where it breaks down. Definitely. So, just like traditional economics would predict, as you raise the price, you know, search pricing starts to damp and demand. You know, when you go from kind of a surge of 1x, meaning no surge to 1.2, you actually see a very, very large drop in demand, okay? And that initial drop in demand actually early on when we first started surge pricing at Uber, going from 1x to 1.2x, you would see a 27%
它却失效了。绝对是的。所以，正如传统经济学所预测的那样，当你提高价格时，你知道的，激增定价开始抑制需求。你知道的，当你从1倍的激增（意味着没有激增）提高到1.2倍时，你实际上会看到需求出现非常非常大的下降，好吧？而这种最初的需求下降，实际上在我们优步刚开始实行激增定价的早期，从1倍到1.2倍，你会看到
of points drop in people who would request. After some time, though, like both after Surge has been in the city for a while, and after people have gotten a little used to it, that drops to 7%. So people start getting used to it. It's not such an alien experience anymore. They may not love you at the company because of it, but they're not quite as kind of put off by it as normal. And then as you take up the price further and further,
叫车人数下降了27个百分点。不过，过了一段时间后，无论是在一个城市实行激增定价一段时间之后，还是在人们有点习惯了之后，这个数字下降到了7%。所以人们开始习惯了。这不再是一种那么陌生的体验了。他们可能不会因此而爱上这家公司，但他们也不会像以前那样对此感到反感。然后，当你进一步提高价格时，
you see further and further drops in demand. So 1.2, 1.3, 1.4, you know, people like surged less and less because they understand that they're paying more. The surprising thing is, there is a very, very strong round number effect which we detect. So when you go from 1.9 to 2.0, you see six times larger of a drop in demand than you saw from going from 1.8 to 1.9. So the amount more that you're paying for the trip is the same between those two steps, but 2.0 just feels viscerally larger to people. It just seems a lot like them. It's very easy to understand. Everyone understands and paying twice as much for this trip as I would have.
你会看到需求进一步下降。所以1.2、1.3、1.4，你知道的，人们越来越不喜欢激增定价，因为他们明白自己付出了更多。令人惊讶的是，我们检测到了一个非常非常强烈的整数效应。因此，当你从1.9升到2.0时，你会发现需求下降的幅度比从1.8升到1.9时大六倍。所以这两步之间你为行程支付的额外金额是一样的，但对人们来说，2.0在直觉上感觉大得多。它对他们来说似乎多得多。这非常容易理解。每个人都明白，为这次行程支付两倍的费用。
I saw a paper on the came out on National Bureau of Economic Research a couple months ago. This is by Matthew Bakker's Tom Blake and Steven Tadellis, where they looked at pricing on eBay. And they found something that sounds similar, which is they found that where new price things with round numbers, those things tend to sell faster, partly because people believe that sellers
几个月前，我在国家经济研究局看到了一篇论文。这是马修·巴克斯（Matthew Backus）、汤姆·布莱克（Tom Blake）和史蒂芬·塔德利斯（Steven Tadelis）写的，他们研究了eBay上的定价。他们发现了一些听起来很相似的现象，那就是他们发现，凡是新定价使用整数的东西，这些东西往往卖得更快，部分原因是人们认为那些
who price things at round numbers aren't really wedded to those prices, that they basically put those prices on because they want to move something quickly. And therefore they're actually willing to negotiate with you because they actually don't care so much about what the actual price is. Whereas when you pick a very specific price point, people say, this couch costs $74.26,
把东西定价为整数的卖家其实并不执着于这些价格，他们基本上定这些价格是因为他们想快点把东西脱手。因此，他们实际上愿意和你谈判，因为他们其实并不那么在意实际价格到底是多少。而当你选择一个非常具体的价格点时，人们会说，这个沙发售价74.26美元，
some thought must have gone into this. And I don't have much room to negotiate. And there's no back and forth where if somebody prices their couch at 100, you think, well, why don't I just counter with 50? Then the conversation gets starting from there. Actually, we see exactly the same thing at Uber. And I think that's the main explanation for something really, really puzzling. And that is more people will take a ride at a surge multiplier of 2.1, then would take
这一定经过了一番深思熟虑。我没有太大的谈判空间。也没有来回的讨价还价，如果有人把沙发标价100，你会想，嗯，我为什么不还价50呢？然后对话就可以从那里开始了。事实上，我们在优步看到了完全相同的现象。我认为这是对一个非常非常令人困惑的现象的主要解释。那就是，在2.1倍的激增乘数下，叫车的人会比在
a ride at two. So I described you how, between 1.9 and 2, a lot of people stop taking rides. If anything, people take more rides at 2.1 than they did it to. When it's more expensive. When it's more expensive, it's as if they're telling you, I would rather pay you 2.1 times the normal price than I would to.
2倍的激增乘数下叫车的人更多。所以我向你描述过，在1.9和2之间，很多人停止叫车。如果有的话，在2.1倍时叫车的人甚至比在2倍时还要多。当它更贵的时候。当它更贵的时候，就好像他们在对你诉说：我宁愿付给你正常价格的2.1倍，也不愿付2倍。
And I think just like your intuition on negotiations on eBay, that's exactly the same intuition. I think that drives the behavior here. You know, people, when you tell someone, your trip is going to be two times more than it normally costs. They think, wow, that's capricious and unfair. Someone just made that up. Somebody just made that up. Like, you know, they must have seen it was raining and just decided to mess with me. Whereas if you say, you know, your trip is going to be 2.1 times more than it normally does, wow, you know, there must be some smart algorithm in the background here that's
我想，就像你对eBay上谈判的直觉一样，这完全是驱动这里行为的相同直觉。你知道的，当人们听到别人对你说，你的行程将是正常费用的两倍时，他们会想，哇，这太任性、太不公平了。有人刚刚随口编了个数字。有人刚刚随口编了个数字。就像，你知道的，他们一定看到外面在下雨，然后就决定来整我。而如果你说，你知道的，你的行程将是正常费用的2.1倍，哇，你知道的，后台一定有什么聪明的算法
at work. It doesn't seem quite as unfair. We had the Behavioral Economist, Richard Thaler on the podcast some time ago, and one of the things he was talking about is why it's often hard to find a cab on a rainy evening. And his theory is that this has something to do with what he calls mental accounting, which is the cab driver has a number in his or her head about how much money he wants to make on a given day. So the cab driver says, you know, my expenses are going to be a hundred bucks a day. I want to make a hundred dollars over that. And so when I hit 200, I go home and on a rainy day demand
在起作用。这看起来就没那么不公平了。不久前，我们请行为经济学家理查德·塞勒（Richard Thaler）来到播客，他谈论的事情之一就是为什么在下雨的傍晚往往很难叫到出租车。他的理论是，这与他所谓的心理账户（mental accounting）有关，也就是说出租车司机心里有一个数字，关于他想在某一天赚多少钱。所以出租车司机说，你知道的，我每天的开销是一百块钱。我想在此基础上再赚一百美元。所以当我赚到200块钱时，我就回家；而在下雨天，需求
is higher so you hit 200 faster and so the cab driver goes home and so you end up with fewer cabs with more demand. Exactly. Now, you've done some work looking at dynamic pricing and search pricing and you're finding that actually that isn't the case with Uber driver. Uber drivers do not necessarily go home when it's actually a smart time to be driving. Yeah, exactly right. I find very different results than Dick does with New York City cab drivers. And I think I understand a little bit of the psychology as to why we're finding different things.
更高，所以你更快地赚到了200块钱，于是出租车司机就回家了，结果就是需求增加的同时出租车反而变少了。完全正确。现在，你做了一些关于动态定价和激增定价的研究，你发现对于优步司机来说，实际情况并非如此。优步司机并不一定会在正适合开车的时候回家。是的，完全正确。我发现的结果与迪克（Dick）对纽约市出租车友的研究结果非常不同。我想我稍微理解了为什么我们会发现不同结果背后的心理学原因。
So exactly as you said, if you're a New York City cab driver, you're going to get the same amount for every trip, no matter what. It's a regulated fare. So when it's raining, the only thing that's really changing is you're just picking up more people, right? So in that world it does feel very salient, you know You're many of them are collecting cash you can just see you know once there's a pile of two hundred dollars in the front seat I'm just gonna call it a day. No thing right? Whereas on Uber, you know the the the main way that we incentivize drivers to move to the places that riders need them, and to stay out a little longer if they can afford to, is through search pricing. And so I think that's very, very salient. So if you're an Uber driver and say you were planning
所以，正如你所说，如果你是一名纽约市的出租车司机，无论如何，你每趟行程得到的金额都是一样的。这是受管制的车费。所以在下雨天，唯一真正改变的是你只是接到了更多的人，对吧？所以在那个世界里，这确实感觉非常显著，你知道的，他们中的许多人都在收现金，你就能看到，你知道的，一旦前座上有一堆二百美元，我今天就收工了。就是这样，对吧？而在优步，你知道的，我们激励司机前往乘客需要他们的地方，并在他们负担得起的情况下多待一会儿的主要方式，是通过激增定价。所以我觉得这非常非常显著。所以如果你是一名优步司机，比方说你原本计划
to do about a two hour shift this afternoon, you're driving around, but all of a sudden, about a two hour shift this afternoon. You're driving around, but all of a sudden, unexpectedly, it starts to surge 2.1 times. Like every trip you're gonna make, you know, I can't believe my mind just went to 2.1. But you're an Uber driver, and it's surging, you're gonna get twice as much for every additional trip you do. What I actually see in our Uber data is that even compared to yourself a week ago in exactly
今天下午开大约两个小时的车，你在四处开车，但突然之间，大约今天下午两个小时的班。你在开车，但突然之间，出乎意料的是，价格开始以2.1倍激增。就像你要做的每一趟行程，你知道的，我真不敢相信我的大脑刚才怎么会想到2.1。但你是一名优步司机，价格在激增，你每多做一趟行程就能得到双倍的收入。我在我们的优步数据中实际看到的是，甚至与一周前的你自己处于完全
this situation, Uber drivers will double, triple the length of the shift that they were planning to do. If it's surging 2X, if it's surging 3X, they're just going to stay out because they can make a lot of money right now. They can take the whole weekend off if they put in another few hours today. When you yourself use Uber as a rider, what is it you pay attention to? I mean, do you use your own trips as sort of research into how the company is working? You must, it's unbelievable.
这种情况下相比，优步司机将他们原本计划的班次长度延长了一倍、三倍。如果激增2倍，如果激增3倍，他们就会留在外面，因为他们现在能赚很多钱。如果他们今天再多工作几个小时，他们就可以整个周末都放假。当你自己作为乘客使用优步时，你最关注的是什么？我的意思是，你会把自己的行程作为研究公司运作方式的一种方式吗？你一定会的，这太不可思议了。
Oh my God, I do all of the time. And it frustrates me because I kind of see so many kind of psychological biases in my own life. Like what? So, for example, partially because I think it's just one of our most exciting products, I take Uber Poole a lot. So Uber Poole is this service by which now up to three passengers can share the same Uber car.
哦天哪，我无时无刻不在这么做。这让我很沮丧，因为我在自己的生活中看到了这么多的心理偏见。比如什么？所以，举个例子，部分原因是我认为这是我们最令人兴奋的产品之一，我经常使用拼车服务（Uber Pool）。所以Uber Pool这项服务可以让多达三名乘客共享同一辆优步汽车。
And when you're in the car, you can just somebody just kind of two blocks ahead, it just happens to be going along the exact same route that you are. You know, we'll just suddenly tell your Uber driver pull over and take up this new person. And then because that we can get people to share rides and get more people into seats, we can reduce the price. And on average, Uber pool can save up to 50% for most people's rides. Not to mention saving on gas, emissions and all the environmental emissions.
当你在车里时，可能刚好有人在两个街区外，碰巧和你走完全相同的路线。你知道的，我们突然就会告诉你的优步司机靠边停车，接上这个新乘客。然后因为我们可以让人们拼车，让更多的人坐上座位，我们可以降低价格。平均而言，Uber pool可以为大多数人的行程节省高达50%的费用。更不用说节省汽油、尾气排放和所有的环保排放了。
And increases driver pay because literally now drivers can be constantly utilized. They can be constantly making money and they don't have any of that downtime of driving to someone or sitting idle somewhere. But a big part of making Uber pool work is minimizing the amount of psychological frustration that people have with that experience.
并且提高了司机的收入，因为从字面意义上讲，现在司机可以得到持续的利用。他们可以源源不断地赚钱，并且没有任何载客去找人或在某处闲坐的停工期。但是让Uber pool发挥作用的一个重要部分，是尽量减少人们对这种体验的心理沮丧感。
And so for example, I find for myself that initially when we were writing those kind of uber pool algorithms, we took a very rational view. We want to pass people the most amount of savings that we can and it convenience them as little as possible within convenience usually being kind of just really, really focused on how much time is it going to get you from your point A to your point B. One of the things that we've started to discover is that, and that I feel very viscerally when I'm in an Uber pool, is that there's something really, really psychologically painful about going backwards. So even if this is an amazing match for you,
所以例如，我发现对我自己来说，最初我们在编写那些Uber pool算法时，我们采取了非常理性的观点。我们希望把最大幅度的节省传递给人们，并尽可能少地给他们带来不便，这种不便通常只是非常非常专注于花多少时间把你从A点送到B点。我们开始发现的一件事是，当我在乘坐Uber pool时，我切身感受到的一件事是，往回开在心理上是一件非常非常痛苦的事情。所以，即使这对你来说是一个绝佳的匹配，
forcing your car to kind of make three right turns and circle around the block and for a short period drive backwards, drive away from your destination is just like three times more painful than you would have expected just from the added time. So we try and avoid that as much as possible. I feel there been times that I miss an exit on the freeway,
迫使你的汽车连续转三个右弯，绕着街区兜圈子，并且在短时间内倒退行驶、背离你的目的地，这种痛苦程度大概是你仅从增加的时间所预期的痛苦的三倍。所以我们尽量避免这种情况。我觉得有时候我会在高速公路上错过一个出口，
and you know that you have to go to the next exit, and then turn it on and come back, and every inch of the way as you're going to the next exit, you're reminding yourself, I'm going to have to retrace this inch, I'm going to have to retrace this inch, I made a mistake, and it's true, you really beat up on yourself when you feel like you're doing something that's taking you in the wrong direction. Yeah. I'll do crazy things.
你知道你必须去下一个出口，然后掉头回来，在你去下一个出口的每一寸路上，你都在提醒自己，我必须原路返回这一寸，我必须原路返回这一寸，我犯了个错误，确实如此，当你觉得自己做了一件让你朝着错误方向前进的事情时，你真的会狠狠地责备自己。是的。我会做一些疯狂的事情。
Like, I realize the other day that, you know, there's two airports that I can fly out of. I have to fly south, and there's two airports I can fly out of. One of them is north of me and one of them is south of me. I can't bring myself to book a flight out of the airport that's north of me, because I feel like I'll spend the whole drive like going in the wrong direction. One of the things I wanted to talk to you about is that Uber
比如，我前几天意识到，你知道的，有两个机场我可以飞。我必须向南飞，有两个机场我可以飞。其中一个在我北方，另一个在我南方。我无法说服自己预订从我北方的机场起飞的航班，因为我觉得整个开车的过程我都会感觉在朝错误的方向前进。我想跟你谈的事情之一是，优步
is collecting massive amounts of information on what people are doing. And I think a lot of people don't quite realize how powerful this information is. I remember doing a story some months ago looking at some social science research, analyzing how people were using cell phones in poor country, and how the way people use their cell phones and whether they kept their cell phones top-to-top.
正在收集关于人们行为的大量信息。我想很多人并没有完全意识到这些信息有多强大。我记得几个月前我做过一篇报道，研究了一些社会科学研究，分析人们如何在贫穷国家使用手机，以及人们使用手机的方式，以及他们是否把手机贴着放。
So this is a country where you sort of prepay your cell phone. Whether you keep your cell phone prepaid and whether you have a lot of incoming calls, or you have a lot of outgoing calls, how wide your network is, all these things can predict with a remarkable degree of accuracy, your creditworthiness. And so if a bank just looks at your cell phone usage data, it can make remarkably accurate predictions about whether you're likely to repay a loan or not repay a loan. And I mean, who would think that just the way that you're using your cell phone could tell a bank that they should give you a loan to start a new business?
所以这是一个你预付费使用手机的国家。你是否保持手机预付费，你是否有大量来电，或者你有大量去电，你的社交网络有多宽，所有这些都可以以惊人的准确度预测你的信誉。因此，如果一家银行只查看你的手机使用数据，它就能对你是否可能偿还贷款做出非常准确的预测。我的意思是，谁会想到仅仅是你使用手机的方式就能告诉银行，他们应该给你贷款来创业呢？
And I feel like Uber has sort of similar access to vast amounts of data. I mean, there have been reports, for example, of, you know, so Uber broadly knows where I live and where I work because I'm often taking caps back and forth between those two locations. But let's say one day I leave work and instead of going home, I go to another location, which is known to be the address of a bar. And then a few hours later, I go to another location, which is not my home address. And then I come to work the next morning. You can draw the conclusion of what I was doing that evening. It feels like you actually know more about people's lives than perhaps they realize they're letting you know.
我觉得优步对海量数据也有类似形式的访问权限。我的意思是，例如曾有报道称，你知道的，优步大致知道我住在哪里，在哪里工作，因为我经常在两个地点之间来回坐车。但假设有一天我离开工作地点，没有回家，而是去了另一个地点，也就是众所周知的酒吧地址。然后几个小时后，我去了另一个不是我家庭住址的地点。然后第二天早上我来上班。你就可以推断出我那天晚上在做什么。这让人感觉你们对人们生活的了解，其实比他们意识到的还要多。
We do have it. We do have a access to a tremendous amount of data. And because of that, we have kind of a privacy officer, you know, within the firm. Because of that, kind of even as an employee of the firm, I have to be very, very careful about what kinds of queries and what I look at in people's data. Yeah, precisely because this is people's lives, and you're right that we have to take very seriously this responsibility that we're becoming a big part of how people move around the world.
我们确实拥有。我们确实可以访问数量惊人的数据。正因为如此，我们在公司内部设立了一名隐私官。正因为如此，作为公司的员工，我在查看人们的数据时，也必须非常非常小心我可以进行哪些查询。是的，恰恰因为这是人们的生活，你说得对，我们必须非常认真地对待这种责任，因为我们正在成为人们世界出行方式的重要组成部分。
And we just want to be very careful with that. Have you ever been concerned about the way you're using these services that might reveal things about you? I mean, that's someone who sees things from the point of view of the institution of the company Have you ever been concerned about the way you're using these services that might reveal things about you? I mean, that's someone who sees things from the point of view of the institution of the company and knows how powerful this information is, has it changed your own behavior and how you interact with any number of these sites? Well, now that you're talking about it, I'm getting even more worried.
我们只是想对此非常小心。你有没有担心过你使用这些服务的方式可能会暴露你的事情？我的意思是，作为一个从公司机构的角度来看待问题的人，你有没有担心过你使用这些服务的方式可能会暴露你的事情？我的意思是，作为一个从公司机构的角度来看待问题的人，并且知道这些信息有多强大，这是否改变了你自己的行为以及你与这些网站互动的方式？好吧，既然你这么说，我越来越担心了。
And this might be naive, but I've often thought to myself that, you know, so my experience inside of large companies that have access to these huge kind of treacherotrophs of data is that, you know, you almost always just look at these like broad, broad aggregates. And I guess I've always just taken comfort in the fact that I'm boring enough of a person that no one would ever, no one would ever, I mean it's almost like, you know, so for example, like some people I know, like my sister kind of shreds all of her credit card statements and kind of does everything before she tosses paper in the trash. And I always just throw everything in the trash because I figure like, I just don't feel
这听趣可能有点天真，但我经常对自己说，你知道的，我身处大型公司内部的经验是，这些公司可以访问这些庞大得令人发指的数据洪流，你知道的，你几乎总是只看这些极其宏观的聚合数据。我想我总是从这个事实中寻求安慰：我是个足够无趣的人，以至于没有人会，没有人会——我的意思是，这几乎就像，你知道的，比如，我认识的一些人，比如我姐姐，她会把她所有的信用卡账单都粉碎掉，在把纸扔进垃圾桶之前会做各种处理。而我总是把所有东西都直接扔进垃圾桶，因为我想，我觉得我
important enough for someone to run into my trash. We do though, you know, in the Uber, see a lot of really, really interesting patterns. So for example, a data scientist named Peter at Uber discovered someone accidentally that was really, really interesting fact. And that is one of the strongest predictors of whether or not you're going to be sensitive to surge. In other words, whether or not you're going to say, 2.2, 2.3, I'll give it a 10-10 to 15 minutes to see if surge goes away. Is how much battery you have left on your cell phone? Oh, that's fascinating. Yeah, when your cell phone is down to below
还没重要到让人去翻我的垃圾桶。不过，你知道的，在优步，我们确实看到了很多非常非常有趣的模式。例如，优步的一位名叫彼得（Peter）的数据科学家偶然发现了一个非常非常有趣的事实。那就是，能否对激增定价敏感的最强预测因素之一，换句话说，也就是你会不会说“2.2、2.3倍，我等10到15分钟看看激增会不会消失”的关键，是你的手机还剩多少电量？哦，太迷人了。是的，当你的手机电量降到
5% battery and that little icon on the iPhone turns red, then people start saying, well, I better get home, because I don't quite know how I'm gonna get home otherwise. And now we absolutely don't use that to kind of push you a higher surge price, but it's an interesting kind of psychological fact of human behavior. I'm talking with Keach and he's a behavioral economist at UCLA and he heads up economic research at Uber.
5%以下，iPhone上的那个小图标变成红色时，人们就会开始说，好吧，我最好还是回家，因为我不知道否则我要怎么回家。现在，我们绝对不会利用这一点来向你推销更高的激增价格，但这是人类行为中一个有趣的心理学事实。我正在与基思·陈交谈，他是加州大学洛杉矶分校的行为经济学家，也是优步经济研究主管。
When we come back, I'm gonna ask Keith about some of his earlier work, which explores the origin of some very interesting biases. Stay with us. We'd like to say a quick thank you and share a message from one of our sponsors, History. This Memorial Day, the groundbreaking series roots returns with a new vision, a story of survival, hope, and courage. Starring Forest Whitaker, Lawrence Fishburn, Jonathan Reese Myers, Anika Noni Rose,
休息一下后，我将向基思询问他的一些早期工作，这些工作探索了一些非常有趣的偏见的起源。请继续收听。我们想向赞助商之一历史频道（History）表达简短的谢意并分享一则消息。今年阵亡将士纪念日，开创性剧集《根》（Roots）携崭新愿景回归，这是一个关于生存、希望和勇气的动人故事。由福里斯特·惠特克（Forest Whitaker）、劳伦斯·菲什伯恩（Laurence Fishburne）、乔纳森·莱斯·迈勒斯（Jonathan Rhys Meyers）、阿尼卡·诺尼·罗斯（Anika Noni Rose）、
on a Pacquan, TIPTI Harris, and introducing Reggae John Page, and Malachi Kirby as Kuntikinté. The journey of an American family begins with a name. Roots premieres Memorial Day, only on history. Support for Hidden Brain also comes from Wells Fargo. Wells Fargo understands that you work hard to get the most out of life. From starting a business to saving for retirement, there are a lot of things you want to accomplish. Working together, Wells Fargo will take the time to understand what you're trying to achieve to help you reach your financial goals.
安娜·帕奎因（Anna Paquin）、T.I.哈里斯（TIPTI Harris）主演，并由雷吉·让·佩奇（Reggae-Jean Page）和马拉基·卡比（Malachi Kirby）饰演昆塔·肯泰（Kuntikinté）。一个美国家庭的旅程始于一个名字。史诗巨作《根》阵亡将士纪念日首播，仅在历史频道。对《隐藏的大脑》的支持还来自富国银行（Wells Fargo）。富国银行深知你努力工作是为了充分享受生活。从创业到为退休储蓄，有很多事情你想去完成。携手合作，富国银行将花时间理解你想要达成的目标，从而帮助你实现财务目标。
That way you can care for the people and things that matter most. Learn more at WellsFargo.com slash together. WellsFargo together will go far. Keith, in your life before Uber, you conducted different experiments into the origins of various human biases, including some issues that often come up in behavioral economics. Some of your most fascinating early work was with monkeys, and I understand to conduct these experiments, you first trained the monkeys to become economic actors.
这样你就可以照顾最重要的人和事。请访问WellsFargo.com slash together了解更多信息。富国银行，携手行远。基思，在加入优步之前的生活中，你对各种人类偏见的起源进行了不同的实验，其中包括行为经济学中经常出现的一些问题。你早期最引人入胜的工作之一是关于猴子的，据我所知，为了进行这些实验，你首先训练猴子成为经济主体。
How did you go about doing that? Oh my gosh, this feels like a lifetime ago, but with a bunch of colleagues at Yale University, we set out to answer this kind of somewhat ill-defined question, but one that we were kind of obsessed with, which was, if monkeys were taught to use money, one, could could monkeys be taught to use money? And two, if monkeys could be taught to use money, would they behave in the same way that humans do in all of the kind of psychologically rich ways that we that we interact with kind of prices and think about wealth and think about, think about how we spend our own money. So, basically what we did was, you know, we just,
你是怎么做到这一点的？哦天哪，这感觉像是一生前的事了，但我和耶鲁大学的一群同事一起，着手回答这个有点定义不清、但我们又为其着迷的问题：如果教猴子使用货币，第一，猴子能被教导使用货币吗？第二，如果猴子能被教导使用货币，它们的行为方式会和人类一样吗——以所有那些我们在与价格互动、思考财富、思考我们如何花自己的钱时所拥有的、在心理上如此丰富的种种方式？所以，基本上我们做的是，你知道的，我们
we had a small colony of kapuchin monkeys that were living with us at Yale. I also did some work with a colony of tamard monkeys back at Harvard, and my Yale students were thrilled to hear that the Yale monkeys were much smarter than the Harvard monkeys. I didn't tell them it was because it was a different species. They attributed it to the school.
在耶鲁大学有一小群和我们生活在一起的卷尾猴（capuchin monkeys）。我还和哈佛大学的一群绒猴（tamard monkeys）合作过，我的耶鲁学生们听到耶鲁的猴子比哈佛的猴子聪明得多时，都兴奋不已。我没有告诉他们这是因为那是不同的物种。他们把这归功于学校。
But basically, what you do to teach a monkey to use money is you hire a bunch of Yale undergrads to basically just live with the monkeys for a long time. So these Yale undergraduates were typically psychology majors. They were studying the monkeys for a long time. So these Yale undergraduates were typically psychology majors. They were studying the monkeys for various other things. The monkeys live in a big, spacious, comfortable habitat. They typically ignore the kind of humans that are moving around, but you'd have a Yale undergraduate
但基本上，训练猴子使用货币的方法，就是雇佣了一堆耶鲁大学本科生，基本上就是和猴子一起生活很长时间。所以这些耶鲁本科生通常是心理学专业的。他们长期研究这些猴子。所以这些耶鲁本科生通常是心理学专业的。他们为了各种其他事情研究这些猴子。猴子生活在一个大而宽敞、舒适的栖息地里。它们通常会忽略那些走来走去的各种人类，但你会让一个耶鲁本科生
every now and then just drop a coin on the floor. And we had chose these large metal washers to stand in for a coin. Now, a monkey thinks that's fascinating. Runs over, grabs the coin, kind of chews on it, bangs it on the floor. Every now and then would throw it around almost a little dangerously, but would eventually lose interest in this metal disk. Then you'd have the yellow undergraduates stand there and stare at the monkey with an open
偶尔在地上扔一枚硬币。我们选择这些大型金属垫圈来代替硬币。现在，猴子觉得这太吸引人了。跑过去，抓起硬币，放在嘴里嚼一嚼，在地板上敲击。偶尔会把它们扔来扔去，几乎有点危险，但最终会失去对这个金属盘子的兴趣。然后你会让耶鲁本科生站在那里，盯着猴子，伸出
hand outstretched. Just stare at the monkey uncomfortably hand outstretched. And just stare at the monkey uncomfortably. Almost just got to setting this uncomfortable situation. And every now and then, the monkey would actually pick up the coin and just put it in the undergraduates' hand, like give it back to the student. And then what we did was we trained the students to say, why thank you in really exaggerated tones,
摊开的手。只是不舒服地盯着猴子，伸出摊开的手。只是不舒服地盯着猴子，伸出摊开的手。几乎只是为了适应这种不舒服的状况。然后偶尔地，猴子会真的捡起硬币，放在本科生的手里，就像把它还给学生一样。然后我们做的是，我们训练学生用非常夸张的语调说“哦，谢谢你”，
and then hand the monkey a piece of food. So like a little apple slice. One undergraduate came to be known to the monkeys as like the apple undergraduate. If you gave that person a coin, they would always like hand you an apple slice. Another person was the pineapple undergraduate. And another person was the orange slice undergraduate.
然后递给猴子一块食物。比如一小片苹果。一个本科生在猴子中被称为“苹果本科生”。如果你给那个人一枚硬币，他们总是会递给你一片苹果。另一个人是“菠萝本科生”。还有一个人是“橙子片本科生”。
Now what's amazing is you do this for about six months, all right, nonstop for about six months. And eventually you start to realize that the monkeys understand that this is fiat money, all right. And what does that mean? Well, what that means is, you know, the monkeys had been very familiar with like basic ideas, like there's a lever on the wall. If I pull this lever, an apple slice falls from the ceiling. But money is something fundamentally different. When I find this coin, all right. It's not just an apple lever. It's actually a choice between an apple lever, an orange lever, and a pineapple lever because I can take this coin. I can carry it around with me.
现在神奇的是，你这样做大约六个月，好吧，不间断地做大约六个月。最后你开始意识到猴子明白这是法定货币了，好吧。这究竟意味着什么？嗯，这意味着，你知道的，猴子对基本概念非常熟悉，比如墙上有一个拉杆。如果我拉这个拉杆，天花板上就会掉下一片苹果。但货币是截然不同的东西。当我找到这枚硬币时，好吧。它不仅仅是一个苹果拉杆。它实际上是苹果拉杆、橙子拉杆和菠萝拉杆之间的一种选择，因为我可以拿着这枚硬币。我可以随身携带它。
And I can wait till the, if I feel like having an apple, I've got to run over to the apple person and I can spend it there. Right? Money is kind of fungible across different kinds of foods that I can purchase. So we started to see that. We saw that monkeys started to use these with each other and to save them, to kind of hide them from other monkeys, and then to make very, very rational decisions, rational looking decisions. When the price of Apple doubled, when that Apple undergraduate started only giving one piece of Apple, not two, when you hand it in you know, demand for that, for apples went down and demand for oranges
我可以等到，如果我想吃苹果，我得跑去找苹果的那个人，然后可以在那里花掉它。对吧？货币在各种我可以购买的食物之间具有同质性（fungible）。所以我们开始看到这一点。我们看到猴子开始用这些硬币互相交易，把它们存起来，把它们从其他猴子那里藏起来，然后做出非常非常理性的决定、看起来很理性的决定。当苹果的价格翻倍时，当那个苹果本科生开始只给一片苹果，而不是两片时，当你把硬币交上去的时候，你知道的，人们对苹果的需求下降了，而对橙子
and for pineapples went up. How did the monkeys protect their money? A fascinating component of the of the monkeys starting to understand money was that they they displayed signs that they realized not only that they understood the value of this disc, but that they understood other monkeys recognized the value of this disc. So for example, early on when the money that we were using was these physical discs, it's a little bit hard to shield from other monkeys, right? And you don't want to be carrying all of these things around. So you would see monkeys hide the discs over on the corner under a pile of wood shavings.
和菠萝的需求上升了。猴子是如何保护它们的钱的？猴子开始理解货币这一过程的一个迷人之处在于，它们表现出了一些迹象，表明它们不仅意识到这个硬币的价值，而且还意识到其他猴子也认出了这个硬币的价值。例如，在早期，当我们使用的货币是这些物理硬币时，要对其他猴子保密其实有点困难，对吧？你不想随身携带所有这些东西。所以你会看到猴子把硬币藏在角落里的一堆木屑下面。
They'd hide the discs. Later, actually, we taught these monkeys to use touch pads. And so then, in some sense, monkeys learned to use currency as if it's just in an ATM. And as if it just gets Ven mode or transfer to other players to the Apple guy. So this is like an Apple wallet basically. Yeah, basically.
它们把硬币藏起来。后来，事实上，我们教这些猴子使用触控面板。因此，在某种程度上，猴子学会了使用货币，就好像它只是在一台ATM机里一样。就好像它只是通过Venmo转账或其他玩家转给苹果那家伙一样。所以这基本上就像一个苹果钱包（Apple Wallet）。是的，基本上是的。
They're ahead of us on this dimension. You know, they're completely cashless economy at this point. You eventually got to the point where you would also introduce to the monkeys the idea that sometimes when they would give a certain amount of money to an experimenter, the experimenter might give the monkey three things and sometimes the experimenter might give the monkey three things, and sometimes the experimenter might give the monkey one thing. So in other words, it was unpredictable what the reward was going to be,
在这个维度上它们走在了我们前面。你知道的，它们在这一点上实行了完全无现金的经济。你最终到了这样一个地步：你也向猴子引入了这样的想法，即有时当它们给实验者一定数量的钱时，实验者可能会给猴子三样东西，而有时实验者可能会给猴子三样东西，而有时实验者可能会给猴子一样东西。换句话说，回报是不可预测的，
you taught the monkeys to gamble. Yeah, that's basically exactly what we did. So we introduced them to two new undergraduates. So one undergraduate would always approach a monkey with three pieces of apple in their outstretched hand. Let's call this undergraduate atom. Okay. Would show three and either give over all three or would take two back and would only give one. Then we introduced them to another undergraduate Ben, right, who always showed one. Okay, but if you gave Ben a coin,
你教猴子去赌博。是的，这基本上就是我们所做的。所以我们向它们介绍了两个新的本科生。其中一个本科生总是会带着三片苹果，伸出双手走向一只猴子。我们称这个本科生为亚当（Adam）。好吧。会展示三片，要么全部给出，要么收回两片，只给一片。然后我们把它们介绍给另一个本科生本（Ben），对吧，他总是展示一片。好吧，如果你给本一枚硬币，
Ben would half the time hand over just that one, half the time would add two apple pieces to his hand and hand over three. All right, so now the fascinating thing is both Adam and Ben are presenting you exactly the same deal. There are 50, 50 gamble between three apple pieces and one apple piece, right?
本有一半时间只交出那一片，有一半时间会在手里增加两片苹果，然后交出三片。好吧，现在神奇的事情是，亚当和本向你提供的交易完全相同。在三片苹果和一片苹果之间存在50对50的赌局，对吧？
And you can give the monkeys a lot of experience trading only with Adam and a lot of experience trading only with Ben. So they kind of get that this is a 50-50 gamble. The interesting thing is what the monkeys showed us through their preferences between Adam and Ben is that they experience something just like humans do, and that's this very powerful psychological force called loss a version. And that's the idea that it's more than twice as painful to experience a loss than it is to experience a similar-sized game. Now what does that have to do
你可以让猴子有很多只与亚当交易的经验，也有很多只与本交易的经验。所以它们有点明白这是一个50对50的赌局。有趣的是，猴子通过它们在亚当和本之间的偏好向我们展示了，它们体验到了一些和人类完全一样的东西，这就是这个非常强大的心理力量，叫做损失厌恶（loss aversion）。这就是那种认为：经历一次损失的痛苦，要超过经历同等规模收益的快乐的两倍以上。这和
with Adam and Ben? Well Adam half the time gives you in some sense what he's shown you, the three apple pieces, but half the time he delivers you a loss. He takes away two and the hands over only one. So half the time he delivers you a loss of two. Ben, half the time just hands you the one that he's showing you, and half the time, delivers you a gain. He puts an extra two pieces of apple there and hands you an extra two apple pieces. What we find is that when given the choice between Adam and Ben, monkeys vastly prefer Ben, the guy who initially only shows one apple piece, but half the time gives you a gain, then they prefer Adam who initially shows you
亚当和本有什么关系呢？嗯，亚当有一半时间在某种程度上给你的正是他向你展示的东西——三片苹果，但有一半时间他带给你的却是损失。他拿走了两片，只交出了一片。所以有一半时间他带给你的是两片的损失。而本有一半时间只是交给你他展示的那一片，另一半时间，带给你的是收益。他在那里放了额外的两片苹果，然后交给你额外的两片苹果。我们发现，当在亚当和本之间做出选择时，猴子大大偏爱本——那个最初只展示一片苹果，但有一半时间会给你带来收益的家伙；而它们不那么喜欢亚当——那个最初向你展示
three apple pieces, and then half the time delivers you a loss. They, you know, six to one prefer trading with Ben to Adam. And that's fascinating because that cuts against their very, very core instinct, which is, well, if I have got a coin, why don't I go traded with the guy who's showing me three instead of the guy who's showing me one, right? Like every kind of fiber in their body tells them that they should be going for more food, not less. And yet because of loss of version and because they actually feel this very viscerally in the same way that people do, they actually prefer the guy who promises less but delivers more. I have to say that I'm thinking about what I would do in that situation and I have to say I'm clearly no smarter than a monkey
三片苹果，然后有一半时间带给你损失的家伙。它们，你知道的，以六比一的比例更喜欢和本交易而不是亚当。这很迷人，因为这违背了它们非常非常核心的本能，那就是，如果我有一枚硬币，我为什么不去和那个向我展示三片而不是展示一片的家伙交易呢？对吧？就像它们身体里的每一根纤维都在告诉它们，它们应该去追求更多的食物，而不是更少。然而，由于损失厌恶，并且因为它们确实以与人类相同的方式切身感受到了这一点，它们实际上更喜欢那个承诺较少但交付更多的人。我不得不说，我在考虑如果在那种情况下我会怎么做，我不得不说，我显然并不比猴子聪明，
because I would definitely prefer to trade with Ben because you're getting something that seems like a surprise. It's a gift. It's like it's wonderful. It's unexpected. It's happy. And at the worst, it's only going to be what he's promised you in the first place. But with Adam, he's taking away something that you thought was yours. Yeah, yeah, absolutely. And interestingly, we see in our Uber data, this loss of version at work as well. and you can even just feel it psychologically. Like when you're a rider and you know, surge pricing hits, like that's a loss, right?
因为我肯定更愿意和本交易，因为你得到了一些看起来像惊喜的东西。这是一个礼物。就像它是美妙的。它是出乎意料的。它是快乐的。最坏的情况下，它也只会是他一开始向你承诺的东西。但对于亚当来说，他拿走了你认为属于你的东西。是的，是的，绝对是这样。有趣的是，我们在优步的数据中也看到了损失厌恶在起作用。你甚至在心理上就能感觉到它。就像当你作为一个乘客，你知道的，激增定价来袭时，那是一种损失，对吧？
And that feels very, very bad. We've often been asked, well, why didn't you frame surge pricing as discounts instead of surcharges, why isn't Uber's standard price twice as high as it is, and then most of the time you're getting a discount, right? Why not kind of frame it that way? Because behavioral economics would predict that you would actually make people much happier
这感觉非常非常糟糕。我们经常被问到，好吧，为什么你们不把激增定价框定为折扣而不是附加费呢？为什么优步的标准价格不比现在高两倍，然后大多数时候你都能得到折扣，对吧？为什么不那样构架呢？因为行为经济学预测，这实际上会让人高兴得多
if you did it that way. Well behavior like economics would predict that you would make riders happier if you did that. I mean, the critical thing to notice is that we're too excited, Mark, and that move which would make riders happier would also make drivers feel less well. So, I mean, so we had thought for a while, why not just frame Uber's pricing as how much cheaper we are than taxi?
如果你那样做。行为经济学预测，如果你那样做，你会让乘客更高兴。我的意思是，需要注意的关键是，马克，我们太兴奋了，那个会让乘客更高兴的举动也会让司机感觉没那么好。所以，我的意思是，我们曾考虑了一段时间，为什么不干脆把优步的定价描述为我们比出租车便宜多少呢？
Because in many major cities in the United States, we're up to 60% cheaper than taxi fairs when we're not surging. And you know what that means is that you can surge like 2.1 and still becoming basically out even if you would instead just take an taxi. But even though because Uber drivers are in such an efficient system, they constantly have a paying rider in the back of the car. They're actually making more than they would have if they had been working as a taxi driver, framing this to them, oh you're making 60% less per mile than you would if you were in, if you were driving a taxi, that's that's that's that's that would be a cost of this pricing system.
因为在美国的许多主要城市，在不加价的时候，我们的价格比出租车费便宜多达60%。你知道这意味着什么，这意味着你可以加价2.1倍，甚至在如果你本来要坐出租车的情况下，基本上也还能持平。但即使如此，因为优步司机身处一个如此高效的系统中，他们的车后座总是坐着付费乘客。实际上，他们赚得比作为出租车司机时要多，向他们这样表述：哦，你每英里的收入比你在开出租车时少60%，这、这、这、这将会是这个定价系统的代价。
Keachan is a behavioral economist at UCLA. He heads up economic research at Uber. Keachan, I want to thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Shankar, it's been incredibly fun. Thank you for having me on. We'd like to thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Shankar, it's been incredibly fun. Thank you for having me on. The Hidden Brain podcast is produced by Karam Agarakaleson, Maggie Pendman, and Max Nestrak. You can follow us on Facebook, Twitter, and Instagram, and follow my stories on your
基昌是加州大学洛杉矶分校的行为经济学家。他负责优步的经济研究。基昌，我想感谢你今天参加我们的《隐藏的大脑》。尚卡尔，这真的非常有趣。谢谢你邀请我。我们要感谢你今天参加我们的《隐藏的大脑》。尚卡尔，这真的非常有趣。谢谢你邀请我。《隐藏的大脑》播客由卡拉姆·阿加拉卡莱森、玛吉·彭德曼和马克斯·内斯特拉克制作。你可以在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上关注我们，并在你当地的
local public radio station. If you like this episode, consider giving us a review on iTunes. It will help other people find the podcast. I'm Shankar Vidantum, and this is NPR. Thanks for listening to Hidden Brain. You should try out the NPR-1 app for your phone, for conversations you won't hear anywhere else. This week, GuyRaz interviews Ted Curator Chris Anderson. They discuss the secrets of giving a great talk.
公共广播电台关注我的故事。如果你喜欢这一集，考虑在iTunes上给我们写个评价。这会帮助其他人找到这个播客。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。感谢收听《隐藏的大脑》。你应该在手机上试试NPR-1应用，收听你在别处听不到的对话。本周，盖伊·拉兹采访了TED策展人克里斯·安德森。他们讨论了发表精彩演讲的秘诀。
You can find that conversation by searching for Ted Radio on the NPR-1 app, where you can also find stories from your local station and more great podcasts. NPR-1 is in the App Store now. I also wanted to let you know that Invisibility as Season 2 returns on June 17. This season, the show goes to a prison, an oil rig, a McDonald's in Russia, and a beach in New Jersey to explore the worlds of work, family, and government. Catch up on Season 1 and listen to the Season 2 preview on May 20th at npr.org-slash-podcasts and on the NPR-1 app.
你可以在NPR-1应用上搜索Ted Radio来找到这段对话，在那里你还可以找到你当地电台的故事和更多精彩的播客。NPR-1现在已经在应用商店上架了。《隐形》第二季将于6月17日回归。本季节目将前往监狱、石油钻井平台、俄罗斯的麦当劳和新泽西的海滩，探索工作、家庭和政府的世界。请在5月20日通过npr.org/podcasts和NPR-1应用收看第一季并聆听第二季预告。
on app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
应用上。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。